what's the secret to finding truth when
making a documentary I mean is there
anything that you say or do that helps
you find it we could spend hours and
hours and talk about truth in
documentaries because I look I'm I'm a
firm believer that all documentary
filmmaking all media is inherently
subjective you shoot hundreds of hours
of footage only a couple of hours ends
up in your final film there are days
you're not there to cover a story you
have you choose a camera angle every
camera angle communicates a different
emotion potentially you make thousands
of editorial decisions so what's guided
me is that I am NOT looking for the
capital truth capital T truth of a
situation because I think truth is very
elusive and subjective depending on from
what point of view you're looking at it
from what I look for in my films is an
emotional truthfulness an emotional
truth of this about the human condition
or the subject that you're looking at
you know in Paradise Lost it becomes
clear these guys were railroaded but a
different filmmaker would have possibly
made a different film so I think I think
filmmakers who think that they're
presenting the absolute truth about a
particular subject
I have potentially you know certain
certain kinds of films straightforward
history you know I think it's more you
know hitting the truth whatever that
means is possible but what I'm looking
for are the emotional truthfulness of a
situation you know the truth rises to
the top if you allow both sides to have
their say treat the audience like a jury
and not pound a specific message over
people's heads it has always been the
method that I've preferred even in this
film even though it's a film about
denial and genocide there's a section of
the film in which those who don't
believe the genocide took place they're
given a chance to air their views and we
allow
the audience you know we allow the
audience to make up their own minds
about it so to me that's what I mean by
emotional truthfulness you air but you
air all sides of an issue don't pound a
message over the viewers head and you
let the truth rise to the top in crude
you know some people were surprised that
I allowed the executives from Chevron to
give it you know to be interviewed and
to present their point of view about the
case but I think I trust the audience to
come to the right conclusion about the
emotional truthfulness of the situation
and sometimes the emotional truthfulness
of a situation is not necessarily what
you think the film is about you know for
example in crude the indigenous rain
forest dwellers of Ecuador and their
American lawyers were you know making a
case and suing Chevron for creating this
cancer deaths on the size of Rhode
Island through bad drilling practices
Chevron was claiming that that's not the
case and the pollution that's there is
the responsibility of the state oil
company some people may think that I was
making a film about the absolute truth
of that situation for me the absolute
truth of the situation
the emotional truth of the situation
that I was trying to talk about is that
we are destroying the rainforest that
the people who you know most deserve to
be treated well were being treated
horribly and that there was a whole
other set of reasons I was making that
film to bring justice to these people so
sometimes the subjective truth of a
situation is not always what the
filmmaker is necessarily trying to you
know present at least that's how I look
at it
you